une question vous présentez vous bernard
charreyre député des yvelines
de quel groupe vous êtes du groupe
socialiste c'est heavy metal finlande un
bon groupe c est pourquoi pas oui j'ai
débuté depuis combien de temps dix ans
est-ce que c'est plus facile quand on
est député pour se tirer des conseils
parce que ça aide
ça je pense que cela dépende pas du rôle
de
et de la profession que l'on fait quand
on est député est ce que c'est plus
facile avec les gonzesses après pour
conclure écoutez ce n'est pas une
question sérieuse posée une question sur
la fin il faudrait pas question pour moi
sérieuse parce que des fois on est sur
un coup on est sur le on est à deux
doigts d'un elana se casse
je comprends pas du tout sont soucieux
parfois il est là qui sont impressionnés
d'aynac on n'aurait pas pensé m'en tirer
mais comme on le député hop on peut leur
mettre une carte au jeu c'est une
tromperie
non non c'est une vraie question
messieurs juste une question vous vous
teniez la main ce qu'il y a des
relations homosexuelles
parmi les hommes politiques rapport où
ce n'est pas la main d'abord si vous
êtes caresser un petit peu vous avez eu
un début d bon je vous ai vu à une
question jean-pierre quand on est connu
c'est plus facile avec les grossesses
mais c'est plus difficile si forcément
plus difficile mais ce qui le met des
lunettes noires vraiment une question
quand on est un homme politique est ce
que c'est plus facile avec les gonzesses
après d'abord d'abord pourquoi me
tutoyez alors est-ce que je t'aime bien
bon vous devrez sympathique on a pas on
n'a pas vu qu en chambre comme ça parce
que j'ai pas voulu
il est ensemble non je suis la barrière
le député maire de pau et vous avez payé
d'attouchements sexuels avec j'adore
rivette et je crois que ça vaut mieux la
doré que tout le reste de votre avis est
ce qu'elle est bonne mais il va être
j'étais pas jacques simplement est ce
que le fait d'être connu en politique ça
sert avec les comtesses c'est à dire que
depuis que je
et rencontré ma femme qui est
fantastique
alors les gonzesses ne me concerne plus
plu du tout tu t'es fait coupé par un
veto vaut pas du tout vraiment on se
tutoie pas alors un et on se vouvoie pas
voilà dit on ne parle pas chez ben voilà
pas rock'n'roll et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un peu de bleu